france 24 rfi et public sénat présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ici
l'europe au moment où l'europe se
confirme pour faire mieux face à la
deuxième vague du coronavirus sa
pratique démocratique et mise à
l'épreuve par des mesures restrictives
la france elle est à nouveau meurtri par
des attaques de type terroriste et puis
tout toute l'europe s'interroge aussi
sur les liens transatlantiques à la
veille de l'élection américaine
voilà pourquoi nous rejoignons
maintenant duplex de bruxelles didier
reynders bonjour vous êtes le
commissaire européen en charge de la
chance
bonjour didier reynders vous êtes de
nationalité belge vous appartenait
depuis toujours à la famille des
libéraux une famille pro européenne
pendant vingt ans vous avez été l'un des
piliers des gouvernements successifs de
votre pays chargé des finances pendant
12 ans puis ministre des affaires
étrangères à partir de 2011 et vous
découvrez un nouveau domaine en arrivant
dans l'équipe de course où la faune der
leyen la justice votre mission veiller
au respect de l'état de droit ce qui
exige des talents de diplomate
alors première question incontournable
en quelque sorte la france qui est
endeuillée à nouveau par des attaques
terroristes après un professeur des
chrétiens tués à nice votre réaction
finalement par rapport à ce climat on
comprendra que la première réaction va
d'abord aux victimes et à leur famille à
leurs proches on pense évidemment à
toutes ces victimes du terrorisme que
l'on a connue à travers les dernières
années un peu partout en europe
mes pensées vont aussi à la population
de nice à nouveau frappé par la barbarie
à la population française je dirais
qu'il ya une solidarité totale de
l'union européenne avec la population
française avec la république française
je crois qu'on est vraiment confrontés à
une déferlante de barbarie islamiste et
il faut pouvoir prendre des mesures sur
le plan sécuritaire mais probablement
aussi pour agir à l'encontre des
discours de haine qui se sont répandus à
travers toute une série de moyens de
diffusion et je crois que c'est une
attitude qu'il va falloir renforcer à
l'échelon européen dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois ou delà
des mesures de vigilance de sécurité qui
sont prises par le gouvernement français
comme par d'autres
armand ces attaques interviennent dans
un climat extrêmement tendu entre ankara
et paris à propos bien sûr des
caricatures dans charlie hebdo après
l'assassinât du professeur samuel pâtit
qui avait montré ses caricatures à ses
élèves
est-ce qu'on a encore aujourd'hui en
europe la liberté de caricaturer c'est
devenu un sport trop dangereux quel est
votre opinion à l'opinion sait qu'il
faut défendre la liberté d'expression et
notamment à travers les caricatures
comme à travers beaucoup d'autres moyens
d'expression il ya une solidarité totale
avec le discours qu'a tenu emmanuel
macron au lendemain de ce terrible
assassinat de cette décapitation de
samuel bâti en rappelant la volonté de
défendre les libertés d'expression qui
fait partie des valeurs de l'union
européenne qui fait partie du socle
commun que partagent tous les états
européens dont je crois qu'on a vraiment
continuer à défendre très fortement
cette liberté d'expression mais je
disais tout à l'heure il faut aussi que
l'on soit très attentif à d'autres types
de discours des discours de haine qui se
répandent de plus en plus pas seulement
dans dans la presse classique parfois
mais surtout sur des réseaux sociaux et
on travaille beaucoup avec les
plateformes d'ailleurs pour essayer de
faire en sorte qu'on puisse bloquer très
rapidement des discours de haine on a
beaucoup travaillé sur les discours
d'appel au terrorisme sur des discours
dans dans des domaines spécifiques de
racisme ou de xénophobie
on va devoir étendre cette démarche est
vérifiée vraiment que l'on puisse
bloquer suffisamment tôt tout ce qui
conduit à la violence et on l'a vu dans
un certain nombre d'attentats islamistes
on aura au départ toute une série de
messages qui sont diffusées sur des
réseaux sociaux notamment et pour
lesquelles on doit pouvoir réagir
beaucoup plus tôt à leur recherche
tayyip erdogan le président turc il ne
fait pas qu'insultes emmanuel macron à
l'occasion il multiplie aussi les
provocations en méditerranée et ailleurs
en se voulant un acteur géopolitique
turbulent est majeure et ce qui n'est
pas le temps de le sanctionner plus
clairement de la part des européens
voilà le débat a lieu au conseil
européen est évident qu'il faut que les
états européens se montrent solidaires
dans les réactions sur un certain nombre
de situations très conflictuelle
finalement dans lesquels la turquie joue
un rôle majeur on a vu le rôle de la
turquie est venu et sur le théâtre
syrien on a vu aussi évolué en libye on
voit maintenant dans le conflit du
haut-karabakh qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'acteurs régionaux dont la turquie qui
joue un rôle majeur
mais bien entendu en méditerranée cela
va même encore un peu plus loin
vis-à-vis de l'union européenne puisque
certains états membres ou même deux
états membres qui sont directement
concernés
la grèce est échue prg et dont je crois
qu'il faut effectivement que le message
soit très clair le conseil européen déjà
annoncé sa volonté de réagir fermement
je crois que le dossier va être à
nouveau sur la table des prochaines
réunions du conseil
la priorité des priorités aujourd'hui en
europe bien sûr c'est la lutte contre la
copie 19 l'europe se re confine en ordre
dispersé les 27 se sont retrouvés au
cours d'un sommet virtuel ce jeudi pour
un peu faire le point quels sont les
outils pour changer la donne au niveau
européen on a l'impression que ça manque
cruellement
on essaie évidemment de coordonner les
choses au niveau européen vous savez que
la compétence en matière de santé
appartient aux états mais dès le début
la commission a souhaité réagir et
tenter d'apporter son soutien avec des
moyens financiers bien entendu lorsqu'il
s'est agi des dd et amant qui devait
s'équiper en masque dans d'autres
équipements de protection des
respirateurs toute une série de domaines
où on a tenté d'agir en maintenant aussi
d'ailleurs
la capacité d'organiser une liberté de
circulation notamment pour les biens je
parle de ces masses de ses équipements
mais aussi d'autres biens la nourriture
qui doit encore arriver sur les tables
tous les citoyens européens
on a vraiment tenter de coordonner
beaucoup d'action dans investit surtout
énormément dans la recherche pour les
vaccins parce qu'on sait que c'est à
travers les vaccins que l'on pourra
trouver une solution mais c'est vrai ce
qui manque régulièrement c'est la
capacité de coordonner avec un accorde
tous les états membres nous avons mis
six à huit semaines pour obtenir
l'accord des états membres sur une carte
commune donnant les mêmes codes couleurs
pour indiquer la situation sanitaire à
travers l'ensemble de l'europe
maintenant nous essayons
surtout de renforcer avec les états
membres la capacité de testing comment
peut-on tester plus rapidement avec des
résultats plus rapides pour permettre
ensuite évidemment d'isoler les
personnes qui sont manifestement
contaminés on n'a pas mis suffisamment à
profit je crois les mois d'été dans
beaucoup d'états mans pour investir dans
cette logique de test dans cette logique
aussi d'application de traçage en italie
on a vu de violentes manifestations
imposé par pour contre semi confinement
du imposée par le gouvernement compte et
on se demande si d'ailleurs elles ne
sont pas orchestré par l'extrême droite
parfois par les mouvements mafieux qui
met en véritablement en danger la
démocratie
il ya plusieurs choses d'abord je crois
qu'il faut rappeler que nous avons eu
plus d'un million de contamination sur
la dernière semaine on a plus d'un
millier de morts chaque jour dans une
europe est liée aux que vie dont nous
sommes totalement solidaires des
démarches qui sont prises par les états
membres pour faire en sorte de lutter
contre cette contamination il ne doit
pas y avoir de contradiction entre la
protection de la santé la protection
d'économies on ne peut pas avoir une
économie florissante
si la santé des citoyens est à ce point
en danger avec de telles conséquences
notamment les décès et les conséquences
graves les séquelles graves qui reste
après des séjours par exemple en soins
intensifs
alors ce qui est important c'est que les
mesures de protection soient liés à des
mesures de soutien
et là nous avons des mois y est déployé
des moyens importants je rappelle que
l'union européenne a mis 100 milliards
d'euros à disposition pour venir
renforcer le chômage partiel pour faire
en sorte que l'on perde peu de son
pouvoir d'achat
lorsque l'on retrouve confiné et il faut
continuer dans ce sens
il faut vraiment faire en sorte que
chaque fois que l'on dessine que des
activités doivent s'arrêter le soutien
soit là c'est probablement le manque de
soutien a parfois qui entraîne aussi la
réaction d'un certain nombre d'habitants
de citoyens qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi on leur demande d'arrêter leurs
activités mais que le soutien ne soit
pas là et donc on a ouvert les vannes si
j'ose dire pour faire en sorte qu' on
puisse réellement renforcée ce soutien
mais nous sommes aussi très attentifs
aux violations éventuelles des droits
des citoyens des droits individuels des
valeurs fondamentales
je prends un exemple très simple je suis
en contact
permanent avec les états membres sur la
libre circulation alors bien sûr pour
des raisons sanitaires on peut limiter
l'accès à son pays on essaie que les
frontières ne soit pas fermée mais on ne
doit pas faire de discrimination entre
et amant ces derniers jours nous avons
beaucoup discuté avec les autorités
hongroises qui limitait l'accès au
territoire sauf pour les pays voisins je
pense à la tchéquie à la slovaquie à la
pologne cette discrimination n'a pas
lieu d'être donc il faut intervenir en
la matière le bon respect de l'état de
droit doit être une condition pour
accéder aux crédits du plan de relance
européen le fameux plan les européens
sont d'accord là-dessus à l'exception
toujours de la pologne et de la hongrie
qui se sentent visés par ces questions
d'état de droit est ce qu'on est sur le
point de surmonter leurs réticences et
de quelle manière il ya deux façons de
réagir pour protéger le budget européen
a finalement l'argent des citoyens
européens des contribuables européens à
qui on demande une solidarité face à
cette crise qui a frappé différemment
des différents états et on sait que les
états n'ont pas la même capacité de
réagir
alors on réagit à travers une lutte
contre les fraudes contre la corruption
contre les éléments qui peuvent être
criminel finalement dans l'utilisation
des moyens européens ça ce sera en
particulier avec le parquet européen
pour la première fois on pourra lancer
des investigations et des poursuites au
niveau européen mais vous savez que tous
les états ne participe pas à cette
logique du parquet européen notamment à
nouveau la pologne et la hongrie sont
restés en dehors il ya 22 états qui
participent et donc à côté de cela nous
avons aussi dit il faut que l'on fasse
un lien entre les moyens qui vont être
mis à disposition et le respect de
l'état de droit c'est à dire le fait que
les états partagent en réalité les mêmes
valeurs et nous font nous progressons
sur le sujet ce qu'il nous faut vraiment
c'est un mécanisme efficace un mécanisme
où on puisse déclencher rapidement une
procédure si l'on constate que d état ne
respecte pas l'état de droit ne
respectent pas les mêmes valeurs et donc
dans ce cas-là suspendre ou arrêter des
financements en protégeant bien entendu
le bénéficiaire final parce que s'agit
pas de sanctionner des citoyens lorsque
l'état de droit n'est pas respecté dans
un état il s'agit d'agir
à l'encontre de l'utilisation par les
pouvoirs publics décident des fonds
européens
alors c'est un débat difficile parce que
c'est vrai que certains états sont très
réticents mais je pense que nous allons
arriver à un mécanisme assez efficace
permettant de lancer des procédures et
s'il le faut de demander au conseil
européen d'aller vers des suspensions de
financement sur les valeurs européennes
envoient en ce moment les manifestations
se succèdent et en pologne des femmes
des jeunes sont dans la rue pour
protester contre la quasi interdiction
de l'avortement suite à une décision du
tribunal constitutionnel le parti au
pouvoir ultraconservateur et bien sûr
ébranlé alors est ce que le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps est
aujourd'hui une valeur européenne et
comment vous interpréter ces
manifestations en signe de vitalité de
ranguin démocratique en pologne
alors d'abord c'est une valeur
européenne bien entendu partagé par un
très grand nombre d'états et de citoyens
européens mais vous savez que cette
partie du droit n'est pas nécessairement
de la compétence de l'union européenne
alors comment peut-on intervenir comment
peut-on agir
je dirais tout d'abord que c'est le
débat fondamental sur l'état de droit
parce que dans le débat sur l'état de
droit nous avons publié à la fin du mois
de septembre le premier rapport annuel
sur l'état de droit dans les 27 états
membres
le premier chapitre dans chaque état
membre concerne l'indépendance de la
justice
si vous n'avez pas une justice
indépendante vous pouvez avoir des
dérives nous avons émis des doutes
devant la cour de justice européenne sur
l'indépendance du tribunal
constitutionnel en pologne
c'est ce tribunal qui vient de mettre à
mal la situation des femmes à travers
une remise en cause de l'avortement
donc on voit que dans la vie quotidienne
des citoyens et des citoyennes il y a un
lien entre l'état de droit
l'indépendance de la justice et des
décisions qui vont aussi loin dans la
démarche alors bien entendu que nous
sommes très désireux de soutenir les
droits des femmes dans l'espèce en
pologne à travers ce droit à
l'avortement je constate que la pression
qui est mise dans le débat en pologne
même à travers des manifestations
la pression que nous mettons aussi dans
le débat sur l'état de droit font qu'il
ya des évolutions j'ai vu que le
président polonais avait avait réagi en
en souhaitant au moins revenir avec une
législation plus favorable sur
l'avortement
je crois que c'est un travail que nous
devons mener ensemble alors justement
nous sommes à la veille de l'élection
américaine présidentielle bien sûr et
donald trump pour certains européens
pour la plupart d'ailleurs à saper les
fondements du mat multilatéralisme et le
lien transatlantique pour d'autres eh
bien il fait figure de champion quel
serait le meilleur candidat pour lieu
candidat américain
ça vous comprendrez que pour moi le
meilleur candidat ce sera le candidat
que choisiront les américains nous
défendons d'état de droit nous défendons
les principes démocratiques dont blaise
et les citoyennes et les citoyens
américains s'exprimer mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que nous souhaitons
continuer à défendre de multilatéralisme
et là il est vrai que l'on a été
confrontée ces dernières années à des
chocs importants dans toute la sphère
multilatérale on l'a vu à l'oeuvre à
l'occasion des discussions sur
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
l'horizon mondiale de la santé y compris
pendant la pandémie on a vu également
dans d'autres cadres notamment en
matière de sécurité au sein de l'otan
donc nous nous souhaiterions de toute
façon avec les partenaires américains
on est l'occasion de relancer un
processus multilatéral dans le domaine
d'ailleurs dont je m'occupe à la la
commission
nous sommes actuellement en discussions
avec les états unis sur la problématique
de la protection des données
personnelles
si on veut permettre l'échangé de
données personnelles entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis
bah il faut que l'on trouve des
aménagements pour que ces données soient
protégés aussi aux états unis donc il
faut que les états unis acceptent un
dialogue dans ce cas-là bilatérales mais
dans beaucoup d'autres domaines un
dialogue multilatéral
mais quel est le souhait qu'elle est la
priorité que se fixent l'europe revoir
sa relation transatlantique
nous souhaitons avoir une relation
transatlantique forte faut pas se
tromper nous avons un lien avec les
états unis avec la population américaine
avec un très grand nombre d'acteurs
économiques sociaux culturels de
recherche aux états unis donc il ya
vraiment pas de doute sur la volonté
d'avoir une relation forte
mais il ne faut pas que l'union
européenne hésitent à jouer son rôle
géopolitique a joué en rôle de 10 d'un
dans un certain nombre de domaines on a
démontré dans le cadre climatique avec
les accords de paris avec les
engagements pris maintenant dans
on l'appelle green deal l'engagement
d'être neutre sur le plan thématique en
mais on doit aussi assumer notre rôle en
matière de sécurité on le voit dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
on doit le voir aussi en matière de
défense et ces dernières années on a
renforcé la politique européenne de
défense
on doit continuer à agir en la matière
on doit aussi avoir la capacité de
développer de nouveaux projets sur le
territoire européen je pense notamment à
l'investissement dans le digital dans
des nouvelles technologies mais la crise
actuelle le démon de la crise du que
vides démontre que l'on doit aussi être
capable de produire nous mêmes un
certain nombre d'équipements en matière
médicale ou un certain nombre de
produits pharmaceutiques demain des
vaccins que malheureusement d'année
c'est peut-être parfois produire trop
loin de chez nous avec une vision à
court terme de diminution des coûts
notamment des coûts salariaux dans
certaines régions du monde alors que
nous avons besoin d'une autonomie
stratégique en europe
merci de cet entretien didier reynders
alors je pars tout de suite retrouvé ma
consoeur de public sénat à bruxelles
pour un débat à l'est tout de l'europe
ce lieu doit elle sanctionner la russie
ou la biélorussie a tout de suite
[Musique]
bienvenue au parlement européen où se
réunissent toujours les députés cette
semaine mais en plus petit nombre vous
allez le voir le constater derrière moi
en raison de la pandémie
nous vous proposons de tourner
maintenant nos regards vers l'est vers
des grands voisins qui inquiète au plus
haut point l'union européenne la russie
de vladimir poutine et la biélorussie
d'alexandre loukachenko
face aux dérives au drouot autocratique
et aux tentatives d'ingérence dans les
démocraties européennes les vingt-sept
ont décidé de sanctions à l'encontre de
hauts dignitaires des deux régimes mais
suffisant pour changer la donne
la russie est accusé de l'empoisonnement
par un agents neurotoxiques d'alexina
leva ni principal opposant au président
russe
quant au président biélorusse non
reconnu par bruxelles il poursuit sa
répression en pleine grève générale
voilà pourquoi nous avons invité
aujourd'hui deux eurodéputés passionné
par cette région bernard guetta bonjour
bonjour à vous saviez au sein du groupe
i knew you drop et de la délégation
ue-russie aussi ici au parlement ancien
journaliste vous avez couvert d'ailleurs
la chute du bloc soviétique vous
dépensez vous défendez la liberté de
pensée sans risquer sa vie et fassent
avoue thierry mariani ancien ministre de
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui eurodéputé
du rassemblement national et vous
appartenez à la commission sur
l'ingérence étrangère une nomination
décrié un car vos liens avec la russie
de poutine sont soulignés favorables à
l'annexion de la crimée et vous avez
organisé une visite de parlementaires
français polémique pour maintenir un
dialogue avec la russie alors l'union
européenne elle a l'air en tout cas sur
ce dossier en quelque sorte de se
réveiller à la mi octobre elle a
sanctionné plusieurs proches de vladimir
poutine jugés responsables de
l'empoisonnement en russie de l'opposant
alex alexis navalni et de parts par un
neurotoxique interdit en plus il était
temps vous avez envie de dire mais côté
pourquoi dites-vous l'union européenne
se réveille au moment de l'annexion de
la crimée par la fédération
russie l'union européenne avait déjà
pris des sanctions contre la russie des
sanctions économiques importantes
d'ailleurs qui ont pesé sur l'économie
russe d'une manière je ne dirais pas
décisive mais certainement importante
non il n'ya pas un réveil de l'union
européenne
il y a une politique de plus en plus
déterminés de sanctionner non pas
seulement la russie mais de sanctionner
et de dénoncer tous les abus de pouvoir
et toutes les atteintes aux libertés et
aux droits de l'homme à travers le monde
s'est souvent moqué par les amis de
monsieur mariani
mais tous les tous les mois en session
plénière le parlement européen adopte
une série de résolutions dit servent à
rien résolution d'urgence si l'on
servait à quelque chose on ne saurait
depuis longtemps
la russie est sous sanction depuis 2014
puisque la crimée a été rattachée après
un référendum à la russie en mars 2014
donc ça fait six ans ça fait six ans que
la russie est sous sanction et il faut
bien excuser moi il faut mal connaître
la russie de l'intérieur pour croire que
ces sanctions sont dramatiques pour elle
au contraire ça a permis à toute une
série de par exemple l'agriculture russe
de se développer parce que du coup cette
agriculture par exemple est à l'abri de
la concurrence que se passe-t-il avec la
sphère navalni esclave elle n'y a été
empoisonnée semble-t-il oui les éléments
vont quasiment dans le même sens vous
reconnaissez les preuves fournies par
berlin je reconnais qu'il ya trois
hôpitaux qui disent la même chose je
suis pas médecin donc un hôpital on peut
avoir des doutes trois hôpitaux je pense
qu'il a été empoisonné
voilà points mais après par qui on n'en
sait rien je veux dire si demain
quelqu'un est empoisonné en france il
n'a pas forcément été empoisonné par
monsieur macron là c'est quand même
alors on sait que c'est un agents
neurotoxiques est utilisée
traditionnellement par les services
secrets russes n'est pas ce n'est pas du
tout sur la place publique ne peut pas
être c'est-à-dire et les centaines de
personnes ayant accès parce que les
services secrets russes il ya pas une
seule personne qui est monsieur navalni
et d'où tient-il sa popularité en russie
il tient sa popularité d'abord parce
qu'il a une lutte efficace
sur la corruption il est spécialiste en
connaissant un certain nombre de lits
gars que russes qui ont été victimes de
monsieur navalni parce qu'il était
corrompu
qu'est-ce que je me fais nationale
vanille sa spécialité c'est prendre avec
des drones par exemple les propriétés
des uns ou des autres
et aujourd'hui en réalité c'est pas du
tout en danger pour le pouvoir
faut être pardonnez-moi abrutis
sorédiens les originaires qui sont
proches du kremlin
alors ça va les gars qui sont totalement
indépendants donc le snav années en paix
dans ce que je veux dire par là que
monsieur navalni et était en une
tentative d'empoisonnement
ça semble plausible que cela soit
ordonnée par le kremlin
c'est ridicule une des grandes marques
du régime de monsieur poutine et que les
opposants moeurs régulièrement sous le
règne où la présidence de monsieur
poutine ce que ses opposants soient des
opposants politiques qui soient des
journalistes qu'ils soient des
intellectuels qu'ils soient des hommes
politiques de région très éloignée de
moscou ou au contraire des personnalités
de stature nationale c'est dans les
régions très éloignées et via les ces
gens là meurent régulièrement très
régulièrement et si l'avion qui
transportait monsieur navalni revenant
de l'extrême orient russe
objet de théâtre de manifestations
depuis le mois d'août dernier
et bien si cet avion ne s'était pas
posée monsieur navalni seraient morts
dans cet avion
avant d'arriver à moscou alors vous
dites et vous avez tout à fait raison
qu'il n'y a pas de preuve que monsieur
poutine et personnellement ordonné
c'est bien le connaître et
personnellement je ne le reconnais pas
je le dis mes premières questions est-ce
que
des membres des services de
renseignement car nous sommes d'accord
sur un point au moins
l'empoisonnement a été l'oeuvre d'hommes
des services de renseignement lesquels
je ne sais pas vous ne le savez pas on
ne le sait pas avec ce n'est pas
d'accord là-dessus prendre l'oeuvre de
gens qui ont accès à des aides versées à
la meinau boucle son tour accès sont
plutôt des hommes des services de
renseignements mais bien sûr que oui
alors non kicking à feu vert directe de
monsieur poutine ou que monsieur poutine
et laissé comprendre
on ne le sait pas mais est ce que vous
croyez véritablement qu'une enquête de
la justice russe pour elle déterminée
non évidemment savoir une enquête
conjointe n'ont eu qu'à l'europe homme
qui aimait manque d'inr c'est la
présomption de culpabilité
désormais les facile je vois ici c'est
peu il est précisé pas d'atouts mais
monsieur monsieur mariani je viens de
vous dire au contraire vous m'avait même
dit et bien de le reconnaître qu'on
n'avait pas évidemment pas la preuve
alors pourquoi pouvoir que les sanctions
mais on n'a pas voté des sanctions lui
dire elle a pas de voter de sanctions
contre monsieur poutine personnel moi
c'est les contredire sonates et des
services secrets russes et deux des gens
qui s'occupent de ce genre d'affaires
est d'ailleurs l'union européenne vient
aussi de sanctionner par la même
occasion deux espions russes pour la
cyberattaque de 2015 contre le parlement
allemand le bundestag l'allemagne qui
préside en ce moment la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne
donc des sanctions contre ces exclusions
russe
ici c'est un symbole quand même de d'une
démocratie fonctionne hante le bundestag
là vous dites vous reconnaissez que
c'était c'est très bien la fraude et
russe ah ben écoutez si c'est prouvé que
c'est la faute des rues c'est très bien
de les sanctionner
une démocratie qui fonctionnerait
correctement c'est une démocratie qui
sanctionnerait tous les esprits de tous
les espionnages j'ai pas souvenir que
l'allemagne et sanctionner les états
unis après qu'ont éprouvée elle a eu les
états unis vous avez raison voilà l
adversaire le reconnaître mais je ne le
reconnais pas je le dis eh bien voilà on
est d'accord au moins pour une fois une
vraie démocratie elle devrait
sanctionner les russes quand ils
espionnent l'allemagne et les américains
quand il est là le mal qui ronge le
tracé
on n'en sanctionne jamais les américains
qui se sentent tout permis en europe en
l'occurrence monsieur je vais embrasser
les espionnages je vous fais remarquer
que les états unis espionne certainement
certainement espionner madame merkel
sans doute tous les autres dirigeants
européens mais à ma connaissance il n'y
a pas eu d'assassinât politique organisé
en europe il ya pas eu d une apolitique
organisé en allemagne par les russes
n'ont plus justes l'année scolaire c'est
ce que je vous dit il n'y a pas eu
d'assassinât politique organisée par les
états unis dans les pays d'europe
bernard guetta est ce qu'il fallait plus
loin dans les sanctions et coupé le gaz
c'est à dire entre et le projet nord
stream ses gazoducs un construit avec
l'allemagne sous la baltique et contreur
contournant l'ukraine
je pense que vis-à-vis du régime de
monsieur poutine noter que jeudi le
régime de monsieur poutine est pas la
russie il faut avoir une approche double
évidemment qu'il faut sanctionner des
comportements inadmissibles que ce soit
la nation de vallées les mêmes lois que
ce soit l'annexion de la crimée où la
tentative d'assassinât contre monsieur
vallini
mais en même temps il faut envoyer le
signal que nous sommes disposés que nous
souhaitons avoir un dialogue avec la
fédération de russie sur deux points
premièrement la coopération économique
et deuxièmement la l'organisation d'un
système de sécurité continentale alors
vraiment sur ce point là monsieur
mariani la biélorussie c'est l'autre
grand chapitre qui concerne l'union
européenne puisque c'est à ses portes
qui a fait l'objet de sanctions puisque
l'élection le 9 août du président
loukachenko est mise en cause par
l'ensemble des dirigeants européens qui
disent qu'elle n'est pas régulière alors
vous reconnaissez ce président est ce
qu'il ne tient que grâce à vladimir
poutine
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
on s'aperçoit que sélection en bélarus
est contesté par une part semble-t-il
majoritaire du peuple du bélarus
la question c'est comment on sort de
cette situation avec un président
qui s'est proclamé qui est décidé à
rester et une partie de la population
qui est décidé à le renverser
je pense une fois de plus pas en votant
des sanctions en décidant de tout seul
que mal un petit canot sky a été lu il
ya un autre précédent depuis que ce qui
est le venezuela depuis que je siège au
parlement européen depuis que nous
siégeons au parlement européen puisque
nous avons été élus ensemble il ya un an
nous pas en sont quand même en même
temps si vous voulez en même temps je
vous rassure
en réalité je crois qu on en est à la
septième résolution est au 11e débat sur
le venezuela et au vote des résolutions
en demande 10 ans le vrai président
c'est guido et donc il faut changer de
président je crains qu'au bélarus en se
soient mis exactement dans la même
impasse
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de faciliter un
dialogue entre les deux blocs
que dit l'union européenne elle a dit
tout de suite monsieur loukachenko n'est
plus président le président désormais
ces malades qu'elle avait raison je vous
invite à lire le rapport parce que tant
de temps il faut lire les rapports qu'on
vote
elle dit tout simplement si on regarde
la plate forme de sondage madame
tikhonov sky a été élue présidente
c'est original est donc désormais
l'union européenne ne reconnaît pas
monsieur loukachenko reconnaît alain
petit canot sky à résultat aujourd'hui
on est exclu du dialogue
ce qu'il fallait dire quand on était
prêt à dit à faciliter un dialogue entre
les deux avant de dire que l'un ou
l'autre avait gagné bernard guetta
cessange européenne
elles ne servent à rien contre le régime
de location comme aux non elles ne
servent pas rien du tout parce que les
comportements aussi inadmissible que
monsieur leucan chaîne où doivent être
d'autant plus sanctionnés que l'union
européenne apporte une aide économique
et financière à la biélorussie alors
évidemment que nous devons pas continuer
à apporter cette aide à un régime un
président sortant qui vient de se
comporter de cette manière les temps
mais vladimir poutine soutien local
tient qu il reste indéboulonnable
alors écoutez ce que monsieur poutine
soutient monsieur le cash est qu
aujourd'hui je dirais qu il le soutient
du bout des lèvres vous avec des
pincettes et je pense pour ma part je
je m'y emploie pour l'instant sans nom
jeudi avec un succès mais un succès très
relatif je pense que l'union européenne
aujourd'hui devrait envoyer des
intermédiaires des go between à monsieur
poutine
en tout cas à l'entourage de monsieur
poutine pour lui ai dit écoutez nous
avons déjà vous unit le problème de
l'ukraine
on ne peut pas ajouter le problème de la
biélorussie au propre modem ukrainiens
sans risquer une véritable
déstabilisation du continent européen
qui ne serait ni votre intérêt ni notre
intérêt ni l'intérêt est évidemment
d'aucuns citoyens européens de quelques
pays qu'ils soient alors monsieur
cousine essayons de réfléchir ensemble
aux moyens d'éviter l'ukrainien nation
de la biélorussie je pense que dans
quelques semaines ou en tout cas
quelques mois monsieur poutine pourrait
seraient susceptibles d'entendre et de
lâcher et de lâcher finalement le cash
and co parce que ce président se prévaut
du soutien de moscou et est dit il son
soutien peut vraiment et ai dit que
c'est que dans ces conditions il n'a pas
besoin finalement de faire quoi que ce
soit contre une société civile qui le
réprime manifestation après
manifestation je crois que l'attitude le
grand gagnant de l'attitude européenne
ce avec la russie et si vous voulez en
sort on verra j'espère dans quelques
semaines on verra qui a raison quelle
était la situation de monsieur du
bélarus
en réalité le bélarus essayer d'être à
équidistance entre la russie et l'europe
et a fait des gestes vis-à-vis de
l'europe etc
la russie essayant le vieux rêve
d'attirer le bélarus est de faire une
sorte de fédération avec le bélarus ici
à économiquement les liens sont plus
solides avec la russie uniquement
économiquement pas politiquement
l'indépendance monsieur loukachenko
justement politiquement et en est
aujourd'hui gelée d'irréel quel est le
dilemme aujourd'hui qu'à monsieur
lukashenko partir il se rapprocher de la
russie et je pense que on verra ce qu'il
a fait
il est allé rencontrer bah oui oui bien
sûr puisque deux façons excusez moi
l'europe et lui dit vous n'avez aucune
place vous devez partir
forcément moi je vous dit vous devez
partir vous rapprocher des sols qui sont
prêts à discuter avec vous je pense que
on verra dans quelques semaines
peut-être que vous avez raison peut-être
que j'ai raison on verra mais je pense
que les grands gagnants une fois de plus
parce qu'ils ne pratiquent pas la
diplomatie j'allais dire moral mais une
diplomatie pratique ça risque avec la
russie qui atteint gentiment que rejetée
par l'europe
monsieur loukachenko s'il résiste aux
grèves générales qui sont en cours en ce
moment où qui sont à répétition ça c'est
trop tôt pour le dire aujourd'hui mais
risque la plus aujourd'hui qu'un seul
choix partir ou se rapprocher de la
russie monsieur lukashenko n'arrivera
pas n'arrivera pas à stabiliser son pays
peut-être qu'il arrivera à se sortir
gagnant d'une grève générale en cours ça
c'est tout à fait possible
je ne l'exclus pas du tout mais en
revanche j'exclus complètement qu'il
stabilise son pays réellement et
monsieur poutine n'a pas besoin d'un
d'une vieille la russie dans laquelle la
déstabilisation s'inscrirait
s'enracinera et il va chercher ou un
jour ou l'autre à remplacer monsieur
lukashenko par un homme évidemment
acceptable pour la russie mais qui
serait aussi acceptable par la
population et ce seront vers les mondes
un grand merci à vous d'être venus
débattre merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis pour rester bien sûr sur nos deux
antennes pour plus d'informations
[Musique]